et
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ses points de vue merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur figaro
live nous accueillons deux invités
bonsoir judith waintraub vous êtes grand
reporter au figaro magazine vous signer
un papier dans le fig mag de ce week-end
qui nous montrent si on avait encore des
doutes que l'université de nanterre et
est fidèle à sa réputation de bastien
gauchistes ont peut être les choses
comme ça il fallait vérifier
voilà il fallait vérifier ses fesses
appelle le fact chez qu'il n'y paraît
aujourd'hui et c'était pas le grand
journaliste laurent joffrin qui va nous
démentira bonsoir langues
on a vite fait de débauche is good c'est
vrai peut-être est-ce que vous faites
partie cette catégorie je ne sais pas on
va vous dire des gens qui vous êtes de
gauche et c'est un coin toujours à la
gauche de quelqu'un laurent joffrin vous
avez été longtemps le patron de
libération du nouvel obs
vous êtes aujourd'hui à la tête du
mouvement engageons-nous qui absolument
objectif de faire émerger une
alternative sociale démocrate à emmanuel
macron en 2022 exactement j'ai très bien
résumé vous est aussi l'auteur c'est
votre dernier livre ce n'est pas le seul
loin de là d'anti macron qui a été
publié aux éditions stock
je propose de commencer par parler de la
pandémie ça n'est pas très nouveau ce
qui est nouveau c'est ce qui se passe en
moselle on se souvient que ce
département vous savez qui est en haut à
droite de la france à la frontière avec
le luxembourg et l'allemagne avaient été
très touché par la première vague de la
pandémie
et bien il semblerait qu'il ait une
sorte de vague spécifique dans ce
département avec des variants de lakovic
19 spécialement virulent écouter ce
qu'en disait ce matin sur bfm tv pierre
kunis et le maire divers droite de
thionville l'une des sous préfecture de
la moselle est depuis le début de
semaine donc ça fait quatre jours on
voit apparaître des enfants des
encadrants aussi dans les écoles qui
présente des quatre copines mais avec le
variant et c'est ça qui pose un problème
parce qu'on est passé quasiment de zéro
pour cent de variants il ya un mois a
désormais entre 30 et 40% de variants
sur mon territoire et je pense que ça ça
nous a apporté une réponse très forte en
ce qui concerne la fermeture des écoles
des lycées des collèges
une semaine avant la date
alors la question est évidemment de
savoir quel doit être cette réponse
forte et les élus ne sont pas d'accord
entre eux le maire de metz françois
grosdidier est favorable à un
confinement 1re confinement alors que
d'autres élus comme le président du
département où le président de la région
grand est
genre tu n'est requis médecins par
ailleurs eux ils sont plutôt opposées le
ministre de la santé olivier veron et
c'est en tout cas dans ce département
aujourd'hui et il a annoncé des mesures
qu'on va découvrir tout de suite j'ai
annoncé d'abord que nous voulions
intensifier la politique de tests sur le
territoire de moselle qui est pourtant
déjà un département parmi ceux dans
lesquels on teste le plus en france tout
cas positifs de coronavirus sera
désormais considérée dans ce département
comme suspect de variants jusqu'à preuve
du contraire c'est à dire qu'il
bénéficiera d'un contact racing
renforcer immédiat d'une mise à l'abri
accompagné immédiate d'une durée
d'isolement porté à dix jours contre 7
jours alors laurent joffrin le
gouvernement reste sur sa ligne
c'est à dire non on ne reconfirme pas
alors même que les chiffres sont assez
inquiétants vous pensez qu'il a raison
ces deux du volontarisme politique ou
c'est une forme d' aveuglement tant que
les chiffres restent ceux qui sont pour
l'instant il a raison je pense que la
société française ne refuse le
confinement s'il ya une flambée
extraordinaire ça se produira
probablement pour casser l'épidémie mais
on voit bien derrière le
et quand même beaucoup de morts chaque
jour et je trouve que le on en parle un
peu moins d'une part et que ça fait
moins d'émotion et que la société est en
train de s'habituer à vivre avec le
virus
le virus quitte à accepter les pertes
humaines
c est s établir le séjour que c'est la
vérité parce que évidemment les on voit
les conséquences désastreuses pas
seulement économique mais également
sociales et psychologiques du
confinement mais même du couvre-feu et
puis de la fermeture de certains
secteurs qui sont en train d'organiser
et pratiquement économiquement parlant
mais également socialement parlant est
donc là je pense que si on arrive à
passer le tourment et accueillait à
quinze jours trois semaines joie le avec
la déclaration du premier ministre en
particulier sans doute cette fièvre tour
on va confie tout le monde c'était il ya
deux semaines c'était vendredi
oui avant de regarder mais vendredi à
quinze jours et là on a senti qu'il y
avait une résistance sourde arrivée d un
disque et je pense également eu peur de
ça aussi il peur de la réaction des
professions concernées d'abord et puis
dès la population qui en a marre qu'on
prend il ya en fait la concurrence entre
deux peurs qu'il devint trop la peur du
gouvernement d'un rejet dur confinement
mais aussi la peur d'élus locaux là on
vient d'entendre le maire de thionville
qui le disent mais attendez ça va mal
chez nous il faut il faut prendre des
mesures fortes
oui mais moi j'ai eu même sentiment que
laurent joffrin et j'ai l'impression
qu'il est confortée en plus par la
confrontation des opinions médicales qui
fait qu'on se dit que entre le
confinement dur avec fermetures d'écoles
on ne sort pas de chez soi sauf sauf
motif absolue et puis
pas de confinement les contrats te
paraissent inutiles très présente comme
vous l'avez dit psychologiquement
socialement le couvre-feu 18 heures
c'est incompréhensible
grosdidier le maire de metz qui réclame
un confinement local dur chez lui
pourquoi 50 quand subitement fin du
dictateur
à quoi ça sert les gens qui font du
bistrot sauvage de 18h à 20h par exemple
n'ont cessé complètement nuls surtout on
sait très bien
on le voit ça a été conforté par une
étude qui a été faite par le chu de
toulouse que ça augmente les
concentrations en rétrécissant les
horaires c'est assez simple c'est assez
simple à avoir donc entre laisser les
gens vivre plus ou mois en l'allégeant
certaines contraintes par exemple si je
suis couvre-feu à 18h ou les musées
fermés alors que franchement on voit pas
pourquoi les musées serait pas capable
de respecter des mesures sanitaires et
des mesures de distance au moins aussi
stricte que dans les transports en
commun ou au travail
en gros ça ne sert à rien d'en merdé les
gens si ce n'est pas pour confiner très
très sévèrement airs confiné très
sévèrement vu le médiocre niveau de
notre campagne de vaccination c'est
absolument insupportable
le confinement duras tenue en israël
parce qu'ils vaccinent est à tour de
bras en main de chant chez nous c'est
pas possible parce que ça veut dire que
quand bien même on réussirait à freiner
la circulation du virus pour un laps de
temps grâce à un confinement dur ça
repartira dès que le confinement serait
levé alors nos internautes sont assez
d'accord avec vous par exemple le
secourisme inquiète
oui mais par exemple sur youtube qui
nous dit les marchés doit à part coller
des amendes et rajouter une crise
économique et sociale ça ne sert à rien
rick haute sur youtube laissez nous
vivre les gens sont responsables
claude toujours sur youtube à force d'en
fermer les gens ça risque de très mal
finir 6ème qui dit qu' il faudrait
surtout renforcer les capacités des
hôpitaux
voilà je peux encore citer elisa le
virus va rester des années on va quand
même pas rester confiné advitam eternam
c'est une histoire sans fin ajoute
alexis le
figaro.fr vous pose la question
aujourd'hui la progression des variants
justifie t elle selon vous de nouvelles
restrictions
alors c'est pas un sondage mais il ya
quand même 50 mille personnes qui ont
voté donc ça commence à présent des
quelque chose et c'est assez partagés
c'est non mais non 1 55%
les français ont encore une hésitation
vous vous pensez de laurent joffrin
en fait ils ont encore peur peut-être
c'est le degré de contamination qui va
jouer c'est si on s'aperçoit que c'est
il ya une explosion ça va s'imposer mais
ce sera vraiment là pour le coup la mort
dans l'âme je sais tout le monde y
compris chez les médecins et je vais
l'aimer gouvernants et est ce que le bar
dans les gens on a vu quand même avant
la fameuse séquence qu'on évoquait il ya
quinze jours
savard confiné c'est sûr à 100% les
volte-face politique m'a constat est
donc ceux qui parlaient en ce moment
pour dire il va annoncer leur
confinement ont pris le risque
mais olivier ferrand militaires pour
leur confinement entre autres et il a
totalement changé de discours quand il a
été démentie par le président de la
république
bon si si la contradiction et le
changement de pied sans se passe à ce
niveau là on comprend que chez les
français jettent pas une constance mais
est ce que finalement l'enjeu français
padilla houle qui a eu raison quand il
disait on en fait trop ou bloquent toute
la société pour une maladie qui
finalement ne touche que les gens enfin
en tout cas qu'il est mortel que pour
les gens très âgés ou très fragile par
ailleurs il va pas d'avoir un droit
d'inventaire là parce que on va dire
mais pourquoi est ce que vous avez dit
vous avez référencement en référence à
raul me gêne un peu parce qu'il a dit
beaucoup de bêtises par ailleurs mais
c'est vrai mais là dessus alors on a
fait trop ils n'étaient pas les seuls à
le dire il ya eu même dhl a fait un
berlin fait un bouquin à en tirer dessus
peut-être c'est possible vous savez
c'est facile à dire après coup on voit
ce qui est certain c'est que le
confinement ça marche dure de
confinement dur ça marche ou ça casse le
ça casse le faisions nous épidémie c'est
vrai la saturation des services
d'urgence ou le premier profil je pense
que l'opinion n'aurait pas admis
le fait qu'on très officiellement et au
vu de tout le monde les malades à
l'entrée des hôpitaux pense que ce
serait me provoquer un scandale énorme
ce qui s'est passé en italie et des
images italiennes ont été décisifs dans
son coin mais c'est vrai qu'à la longue
ça devient insupportable donc c'est pas
tenable il faut apprendre à vivre avec
eux avec cette maladie mais d'autant
plus que les italiens
c'est vrai que les images étaient
affreuses mais ils ont pris des mesures
en septembre ils ont rembauché plus de
15 8 infirmières et de plus de 5000
médecins nous on n'a rien fait c'est
quand même très étrange presque un an
je vous livre cette réaction de jeu
petit 74
ces données mais sans doute c'est sur
lefigaro.fr parce que c'est une voix un
peu discordante
c'est une région un département est en
difficulté elle peut être mise sous
cloche estime-t-il et puis vole pas su
nous dire s'il ne confine pas ils sont
critiqués et s'ils confient ils seront
critiques et c'est vrai que c'est pas
compliqué parce qu'être gouvernants j'ai
eu 20 troubles j'aimerais qu'on revienne
sur ce qu'a dit laurent joffrin sur on
apprend à vivre avec le virus mais on
apprend aussi à accepter les morts du
virus
et ça c'est quelque chose de nouveau
c'est à caen fait peut-être que en
mettant en avant comme on l'a fait
presque tous les jours
le nombre de morts on a déclenché une
espèce de 2,2 d'effroi collectif alors
que aujourd'hui il reste des morts il
plusieurs centaines par jour
et puis finalement on se dit bad pour un
grand pays comme le nôtre c'est normal
comme s'ils avaient une banalisation
ou alors une instrumentalisation de ces
morts
une banalisation
oui on peut le craindre mais ça c'est
presque médaille mécanique
quand vous annonce entre 400 et 500
morts par jour pour la période actuelle
où peut-être entre 300 et 400 l'epic
était monté à 1800 en avril
nous en venons effectivement il ya un
événement de d'habitude qui sait faire
l'expérience historique des guerres
montrent que les populations résistent
les taux de perte élevée quand on la
gagne 14 des français s'est portée
il y avait des jours il y avait 4000
5000 morts dans la journée et le
patriotisme et dans la société française
a continué à fonctionner entre trouver
400 morts 7 402 trop évidemment mais bon
les gens s'habituent
ça c'est sur l'usure et de deuxième
question c'est l'instrumentalisation il
est évident que
jérôme salomon annonçant tous les soirs
le nombre de morts le nombre de
nouvelles contaminations sa visaient à
faire peur et c'était assumé d'ailleurs
quand on vous parle pour la bonne cause
oui quand vous parliez des bancs du
gouvernement et des comportements des
gens voilà il expliquait que sinon les
gens les faire n'importe quoi et qu'il
fallait absolument le faire donc
problème c'est que ça ça use marché ça
ne marche plus encore que on voit pas
tellement de comportement complètement
délirant on n'a pas vu en plus de
protestations forte en france
contrairement à certains de nos voisins
pas de grosses manifs
bon y'a eu quoi mais des teufeurs à en
bretagne il ya pas mal de gens qui
doivent s'arranger avec les règles mais
tout en restant prudent aller chez
n'importe quel marchande veille vous
explique qu'il filait exactement le même
chiffre avec court 18 heures que ip en
tordant mal et que les gens qui arrivent
entre 17 et 18 heures c'est la cohue qui
demandent des bouteilles fraîche donc
ils vont les voir juste après des petits
éléments que ça qui laisse penser qu'on
s'arrange avec les règles enfin on vous
voit pas de clusters qui surgissent ici
et là parce que les gens se rassemblent
et hors de leur foyer et on nous avait
dit ça va être terrible après les fêtes
de fin d'année vous verrez trois
semaines après la flambée qui n'a pas eu
lieu qui n'a pas eu donc les français
sont semble-t-il peut être plus
discipliné convaincront voilà alors vous
êtes tout à fait d'accord sur ce sur ce
thème donc on va changer parce que
peut-être serez-vous moins sur le
deuxième qui sera aussi le second
puisqu'il n'en a pas de troisième
vous souvenez peut-être que emmanuel
macron dans son interview au site
d'information brute avait annoncé le
lancement d'une plateforme anti
discrimination et si vous avez oublié
revoilà la séquence donc le seul moyen
de bouger c'est de faire ce qu'on a su
faire sur d'autres violences ou d'autres
sujets sensibles
c'est de mettre en place une plate forme
commune pour que les gens puissent
dénoncer de manière très simple unique
et national et donc ce qu'on va mettre
en place à partir de janvier prochain
une plateforme nationale avec la numéro
d'appel la possibilité de signaler et ce
sera géré par l'état le défenseur des
droits et des associations compétentes
en la matière en particulier la licra
alors dans concrètement on peut aller
sur ce site qui s'appelle
anti-discrimination point fr et donc
vous allez découvrir la page d'accueil
vous pouvez aussi
enfin on peut aussi vous faites ce que
vous voulez appeler un numéro de
téléphone de 39 28 pour être en contact
avec des juristes spécialisés sur ces
sujets vous êtes allé sur le site dit
racontez nous ce que vous avez découvert
alors ce qu'on voit à l'écran et puis je
suis allé voir précisément vers où menez
les démarches qu'on entreprenait alors
le principe de la plateforme
c'est que vous mettez en contact avec
elle et la réponse vous est fournie par
un juriste
ça met en contact sous l'égide de la ce
la femme qui a succédé super quand même
si ce successeur mal aux défenses
heureux ou la défenseure des droits
caire et dont c'est elle qui a remis en
mai lieu en place a donc vous appeler
pour vous vous connectez et vous êtes
mis en liaison avec des juristes et tout
ça est patronné par des associations
alors je suis allé voir par curiosité
quels étaient les associations en
question je me suis dis parce que par
exemple vous pouvez vous plaindre d'une
discrimination au logement alors
peut-être qu'il ya des associations de
propriétaires ou des associations de
locataires pimpante à des gens qui
connaissent le sujet bah non ce ne sont
que des associations militantes droit de
l'aunis pour utiliser une formule
laurent joffrin affectionne tout
particulièrement
pas n'importe lesquels parce que vous
avez alors certes la licra
alors mon dieu et vous avez eu le cran
le conseil représentatif des
associations noires de france dont le
nom à lui seul état manifestera 607 et
reste qu'à la couleur de peau
vous avez la ligue des droits de l'homme
dans le dernier fait d'armes on l'a
raconté dans le figaro magazine était
porté plainte contre une prof
d'université qui avait osé dire que
l'islam du judaïsme et et des maladies
sexuellement transmissibles sur le ton
de la plaisanterie puisque le judaïsme
s'attrape par la mer et l'islam par le
père voilà donc vous avez des
interlocuteurs comme ça dans une
entreprise confié à une dame claire
hédon dons à des premiers faits de
guerre a été d'accéder à la demande du
ccf le collectif contre l'islamophobie
en france à une démarche
visant à attaquer les mères qui
voudraient empêcher le port du burkini
dans les piscines étaient de première
chose qu'elle a faite quand elle a
succédé à jacques toulon donc vous voyez
que le système clé conçue plein de
bonnes intentions au départ n'en doutons
pas effet comme une mécanisme pour
exploiter le sentiment d'être victimes
dans la société française et lui donner
le plus larges débouchés c'est une
entreprise parfaitement débat gogh
j'ajoute que plein de choses qui
existent déjà plein de dispositifs qui
existent quand vous vous estimez être
victimes d'une discrimination dans tel
ou tel domaine pour prévenir y compris
chez le défenseur des droits d'ailleurs
ça existait déjà
donc donc vraiment c'est une opération
purement politique démagogique et il se
trouve que la présidentielle n'est pas
si loin joffrin je trouve qu'on va pas
assez loin
il ya des discriminations c'est vrai la
principale discrimination dur et
sociales que vous faites le quand vous
regardez la composition des élites
vous êtes à sauver que les fils
d'ouvriers le fils en pays en a très peu
évidemment ces cols notamment l'accès
aux grandes écoles mais même dans la
promotion en général et évidemment ça se
recoupent en partie avec la l'origine
ethnique puisque les enfants d'immigrés
sont en moyenne beaucoup plus pauvres
que les autres c'est pas de la faute de
la société c'est parce qu'ils viennent
pays pauvres ils auront forcément un peu
plus de mal que les autres à se faire
une place au soleil et donc c'est une
c'est une question très importante parce
que c'est un des facteurs qui alimentent
la colère sociale et qui sert de vivier
de recrutement à toul à tous les excès
ce soit le trafic de drogue liste a misé
tout ça ça vient aussi de là vers le
sentiment que dans certains quartiers on
a pas de débouchés dans la société
c'est ce sentiment n'est pas qu'un
sentiment c'est souvent vrai et donc moi
je suis pour une politique plus large de
testing c'est à dire que
le gouvernement doit subventionner ce
nombre d'organismes pas forcément de
l'association militante pour tester pour
voir s'il ya effectivement une
discrimination au logement par exemple
parce que quand on s'appelle mohamed on
est on a beaucoup plus de mal à trouver
un appartement que quand on s'appelle
jean philippe et tutti quanti
ça me paraîtrait logique face à la
république on est tous républicains me
semble-t-il à public vivra vous avez des
chances égales
mais la république ne tient pas sa
promesse donc plutôt que d'avoir en face
de soi des gens qui vont brandir le
spectre des colonials et qu'on concède
être communautariser etc
il faut assurer vraiment l'égalité des
chances indépendamment de l'origine
sociale et de la couleur de la peau et
donc il faut des dispositifs pour ça
quand on a mis en place dès par exemple
la parité dont certains dans certaines
enceintes pour les femmes il n'y a que
ça qui est un marché
tout le monde dit oui les femmes et les
hommes qui sont des gotham ça n'avançait
pas c'est quand on a mis au point un
canton a mis le la parité que ça
commençait à changer à avancer et ça
marche
je connaissais pas soit que au
gouvernement il ya la moitié de femmes
le gouvernement n'est pas plus mauvais
que vous pouvez être avant quand et avec
des hommes c'est une évidence
eh ben c'est pareil pour la ruine c'est
sans doute à cause des participants on
peut discuter de qualité légalement non
c'est pas ça le critère prix bas on ne
peut pas savoir
oui si vous voulez moi je veux bien
qu'on dise que les femmes font baisser
de niveau mais je reste la
responsabilité de ses propos
je ne vous apprendrai pas que la
politique des quotas féconder ses des
quotas de paritaire des femmes ou si
c'est des quotas diversiterre non moi je
vais contre les quotas ethniques à on
pourrait appliquer parce que je suis
content le racialisation de la société
comment c'est exactement le même
raisonnement qui fait par exemple ce que
le résultat est là on va faire une
sélection spéciale pour les gens dits de
la diversité non il faut pas faire comme
ça il faut le faire sur le plan social
il faut pas faire pas d'accord ni là ni
pour la baie
l'unité contre tout le côté je suis pour
les quotas sociaux de manière à assurer
un sexe n'est pas pareil
bah oui parce que oui mais c'est là
c'est pas pour pas mal de colas fils
alors oui oui je vais j'assume tout à
fait mais simplement ça me paraissait ça
me paraît logique dès lors qu'on
programme proclame l'égalité des chances
puisque c'est parce qu'on fait mais non
quand ton statut quand on regarde la
statistique elles marchent pas pour
l'instant à l'égalité des genres non
puisque elle marche mal et elle marche
de plus en plus mal d'ailleurs
est ce que on s'aperçoit par exemple à
la diversité sociale à sciences po et à
l'ena a reculé mais a beaucoup reculé
ces va trente dernières années
alors c'était pas formidable n'y avait
pas c'était pas envahi de d'enfants
d'ouvriers
il ya dans mon sens mais ça ne
fonctionnait mieux non je vais vous dire
pourquoi je porte dans votre force
est-ce que c'est pas en mettant des
quotas en aval qu'on résoudra le
problème se rendent à monza en sorte que
dans les écoles on ne fasse pas un an
100 minutes un enseignement au rabais
dans les zones dites difficiles
or c'est ça qui s'est passé pendant des
années et des années c'était ce qu'on
appelait le pédagogisme c'est-à-dire
s'appliquer à toutes les écoles
seulement oui c'est l'école alsacienne
il vous savez que sauf qu'ils avaient
des effets délétères des gens qui par
ailleurs ne pouvait pas être aidés à la
maison je comprends cela vous apprenez
un enfant à lire par la méthode globale
et que chez lui michael grabner ce n'est
pratiquement pas appliquée oui c'est ce
qu'on dit à chaque fois je crois que
nous en nous qu'on va enquêter quand je
le journal
parce qu'elle n'était pas vraiment
enseigne et autorise alors bizarrement à
partir du moment où elle a commencé à ne
pas être appliquée que vous vous dites
dans les écoles le niveau d'orthographe
s'est cassé la figure d'une façon
extraordinaire
présent sur
twitter nous allons poser la question la
création d'une plate forme anti
discrimination est elle une bonne idée
selon vous ces noms à 66% voici quelques
points de vue à l'appui de cette
prise de dispositions pardon dominante
c'est de la délation dans toute son
horreur estime charles dont bleus sur le
figaro.fr
à part brasser du vent comme d'habitude
nous dit assez sur youtube ça ne
changera pas la réalité des choses
encore de la délation nous dit aussi
elisabeth sur youtube alors que françois
à lui il est favorable si ça peut
renforcer l'égalité entre les citoyens
quel est le but recherché par cette
plateforme à part dénoncer nous dis avec
respect nicole 06 qui considèrent elles
qu'on n'est pas tous égaux dans la vie
c'est un fait
et puis solaires sur youtube et si on
laissait une chance à cette plateforme
c'est contradictoire je vois les gens
qui disent oui les avis divergent
bien des gens qui disent et or il
d'autres qui disent ça change rien il
faut choisir si ça change enfin ne pas
les mêmes oui en matière de
discrimination
on a beaucoup parlé des contrôles de
police dit au faciès
il ya un syndicat de police qui avait
répondu on ne choisit pas sa délinquance
est à dire pour dire des choses un
complément mais quand on va au tribunal
de grande instance de bobigny il ya
certaines et d'appartenance qui sont
plus représentatifs que d'autres et que
donc la police fait avec cette réalité
qu'est ce qu'il reconnaît qu'on contrôle
plus les noirs que les autres oui sans
doute mais aussi c'est à dire on est
content le plus mais il ya des bonnes
raisons pour le faire
ben c'est dire que par exemple quand on
voit qu'il a de même temps quand on est
arabe ou noir et qu'on n'est pas
délinquants bien sûr c'est un problème
bien sûr problème
or la majorité des noirs les arabes ne
sont pas délinquants bien sûr
contrairement au regard même si vous
cherchez dans une banlieue un trafiquant
de drogue
j'entends bien mais vous voyez bien
qu'il ya un problème de riche je veux
mettre sur ce problème comment est-ce
qu'on ne résout alors à ce jour le
réseau en filmant déjà ont mis à une
caméra comme ça on voit qui est
contrôlée qui n'est pas contrôlée et en
faisant des statistiques on peut aussi
la défenseure des droits j'entendais ce
matin à alès elle propose de suspendre
les contrôles pendant un certain temps
pour voir ce que ça donne en affirmant
qu est pourquoi pas laisser contrôler ne
servent à rien alors je suis pas dû à la
tirer de ces chiffres c'est lyon oui
c'est vrai essayons de
c'est comme ça regardez c'est
catastrophique on verra tout de suite
non non mais dans un quartier bas à
l'échelle nationale c'est une idée
amusante
sinon il existe déjà des ddd procédure
assez nombreuses la table y compris
d'ailleurs des actions en justice contre
la discrimination mais est ce que cette
matière c'est pas fini d'ailleurs un
plateformes la plateforme sera soumise à
la loi sous les gens disent et de la
délation la délation ça consiste à
dénoncer son voisin parce qu'on le
soupçonne de faire je ne sais quoi mais
là c'est pas de la délation c'est des
gens qui s'estiment victimes qui se
plaignent en général ce cas c'est la
plainte
en effet quelqu'un quand on est victime
il faut voir ce que commença sera traité
parce que comme je les dis vous
appelez-vous tombé sur un jury ensuite
qu'en fait la défense euros des droits
si elle nous fait des jolis rapports où
elle nous explique que parce qu'elle va
les traiter ces données
elle n'est pas là juste pour mettre à
part les gens je pense que s'il ya un
fait discrimination avérée ça passe
devant un tribunal mais bien sûr
indépendant s'est conduit comme les à ce
que les associations qui la conseillent
en tout cas une majorité d'entre elles
elle peut très bien faire campagne sur
les thèmes qui lui perd on veut mener la
campagne politique c'est évidemment une
femme qui a des convictions politiques
jusque est très bien mais les mais elle
elle me sa cause au service de
convictions politiques
comme on le voit depuis que depuis
qu'elle a été nommée donc c'est lui
fournir un instrument c'est les gens
certains internautes parlent de
discriminer les nombreux tepa landes
gauche ou le contraire par exemple par
exemple savez pas ce que c'est ça oui ça
va se voir mais elle le fera sous les
fils de son effectif n'est pas de faire
des fausses de dénonciation sera
discréditée
dès lors qu'on fait de la politique je
suis je suis confiant dans l'existence
de journalistes par exemple le fier aux
clients qui ont enquêté pour voir si
c'est plein de soit justifié ou pas
j'estime de justice et son prédécesseur
s'est largement
très vite et ça n'a pas empêché de
garder son pas jusqu'au bout pourquoi il
s'est discrédité bien après légal de là
à mon avis dans moins d'un an cette
plateforme sera supprimée d'outils jeu
petit 74 et ça nous aura coûté de
l'argent
les présidentielles oui la craie c'est
une chose à supprimer à la veille de la
présidentielle
à mon avis le signal sera fêté ce
raisonnement donc on suppose donc qu'il
n'y a pas de discrimination il n'y a pas
de problème
non j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit qu'on ne
fait pas un instrument qu'on confie à
quelqu'un qui est quelqu'un dont on peut
douter de l'impartialité politique et
partisane
aidés par des hausses des associations
dont on connaît avec certitude les
crises mais libyenne on a fait appel à
des notions qui sont hostiles à la
discrimination le crâne n'est pas juste
hostile à la discrimination le cran
considère la revois cette tuerie raciste
il ya des flux systémique est ici la
ligue des droits de l'homme pareil la
ligue des droits de l'homme
elle était contre la loi d'interdiction
de la burqa dans l'espace public par
exemple un c'est pas n'importe quelle
association et se veut pas dire nous on
défend les droits pour être président de
ce contre je crois la dissolution de
c'est ce type burqa ses positions là
mais c'est toutes les positions l'air
oui mais la forme est là il s'agit de
discrimination il s'agit pas de la burqa
et elle va devenir vertueuse parce qu'il
s'agit de discrimination pourquoi mais
je sens est contrôlé par les juges ne
croyais aussi est ce que est ce qu'il ya
une démarche politique d' emmanuel
macron vous parlez de la perspective
présidentielle je mène trop de 2,2 en
quelque sorte de victimisation d'une
partie de la société
est-ce que c'est abusif de rapprocher
cette initiative du rapport qui a été
demandé à benjamin stora par exemple
pour parler des fautes de la france mais
pas que c'est vrai dans la guerre
d'algérie le rapport la commande est un
peu différente un ct pacifier la
relation voilà l'histoire de la relation
franco algérienne et ce truc
benjamin stora à certaines opinions
connues d'ailleurs il a fait son travail
d'une façon qui a fait hurler personne
finalement je pense chez nous à jean
sévillia qui avait très très peur
d'avoir attendu voilà un sujet très
idéologique qui est très très très
sentie français très très victimaire
jean sevilla reconnu que le travail on
attaquera ce travail était un peu frais
honnête mais oui il ya celle emmanuel
macron
la volonté de ne pas ignorer et même si
ça peut le servir de récupérer tout
c'est toutes ces tendances
il a dit qu'il était contre les
colonialistes l'indigénisme il a même
dit que de les historiens c'était je me
rappelle plus la formule exacte c'était
dévoyer les universitaires en tombant
dans ces biais là mais existent et quand
il fait une interview quand il donne une
interview à brut
c'est cette fibre là qu'il fait vivre et
celle en même temps mais il ya eu un
livre qui a eu beaucoup de sujets qui
s'appelle l'archipel français peut pas à
la fois à dire l'archipel français d'un
livre comment dire fidèle à la réalité
qui reflète ce qui se passe dans la cité
française
l'analyse politiques et sondeurs jérôme
fourquet voilà et en même temps dire dès
qu'on veut lutter contre les
discriminations essayé de donner le
sentiment aux gens que ils sont à peu
près sur la même ligne de départ c'était
française de dire c'est horrible vous
rendez compte ils vont faire de la
délation c'est des associations louche
ils sont pas d'accord d'ailleurs s'ils
sont partisans et donc on ne fait rien
on a dj 10 étaient des colonies louche
mais ses avis merci beaucoup
lorsque vous vous trompez jeu c'est
irresponsable à mon avis ce qui serait
intéressant ce serait peut-être devrait
inviter dans un enfin j'espère avant
mais pour faire un premier bilan de ce
corps a donné cette plateforme merci
beaucoup à tous les deux merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis excellent week-end et
nous retrouverons si ça vous convient
lundi prochain avec vincent roux qui
présentera point de vue bonsoir
guillaume roquette est en vacances
absolument
[Musique]